the final episode of game of thrones
starts in the ruins of king's landing
thousands of people are dead because
last episode daenerys burned the city
and now grey worm is killing prisoners
he says that lannister soldiers are free
men
who chose to fight for cersei but random
soldiers don't really choose
they're forced into war by their lord
feudalism is kind of similar to slavery
but grey worm has no sympathy and kills
the lannisters
tyrion sees the small council room where
he served in early seasons there are so
many memories here
of tyrion's successes and failures and
his family
tyrion finds jaime and cersei's bodies
under a surprisingly
light dusting of bricks tyrion tried to
protect his siblings from daenerys but
he supported her war because he thought
she would make the world
better now daenerys is a tyrant and
tyrion's family's dead anyway
so all tyrion's work these last seasons
have only brought death to his family
and to thousands of others daenerys goes
full targaryen she gives a victory
speech to her soldiers and it looks just
like a nazi rally with daenerys
as hitler but with a dragon she says
she liberated the people of king's
landing which is delusional
she killed those people after they'd
surrendered
and she says she'll continue her war to
liberate
all the people of the world she mentions
winterfell
and lannisport threatening jon and
tyrion's family homes
she also mentions carth in season 2
daenerys threatened to destroy that city
so daenerys is set to bring death and
destruction to the world
that flaming spiral in episode 1 does
look like the targaryen sigil
turns out the real threat to the world
isn't icy white walkers
it's targaryen fire tyrion quits as
daenerys's hand
and his hand pin looks like jaime's hand
tyrion refuses to follow the woman who
killed his family
daenerys arrests tyrion for treason
because he freed jaime
and tried to save cersei arya warns that
daenerys is a threat to jon
because jon is the true heir to the iron
throne dany is also a threat to sansa
because sansa won't accept her
as queen so daenerys is not just a
danger to the world she's a danger to
jon
and to tyrion and to their families
tyrion tells jon that varys was right
about daenerys
she went bad and supporting her was
wrong so when tyrion ratted out varys he
got his friend
killed for nothing jon tries to defend
dany but tyrion argues that her massacre
was unjust
and unnecessary tyrion says that for the
sake of their families and the world
jon should kill daenerys even though jon
loves daenerys
so once again jon has to choose between
love
and duty this is like when jon gave up
his love egret to stop the wildlings
now jon has to kill dany to save the
world
this scene is similar to when varys
convinced ned stark to make a false
confession
to do something dishonorable to protect
his family
ned was only convinced when varys
mentioned sansa's safety
and now jon is only convinced when
tyrion mentions sansa's safety
so jon is following ned stark's example
even though ned isn't jon's father
rhaegar targaryen is
but as jon says people aren't defined by
their blood
they make their own choices and jon
chooses like ned to do the
right thing even when it costs
everything
daenerys approaches the throne she's
wanted this for
eight seasons and it's not quite how she
imagined
she thought the throne would be bigger a
mountain of swords
in the books the throne is much bigger
daenerys had a vision of the throne in
season 2 and this scene recreates it but
this time daenerys touches the throne
jon confronts dany about the killings
and imprisoning tyrion
dany argues that she has to punish
tyrion for conspiring with her enemies
just like jon has killed people who
disobeyed him but daenerys has no
justification for killing the people of
king's landing
she just says she'll build a new world
and that she knows what's good and that
other people
don't get to choose as tyrion said
daenerys has spent years
gaining power and killing people and
being rewarded for it
she's been surrounded by adoring
followers people who worship her as
messiah
daenerys once said that what keeps her
going is faith
in herself now her faith blinds her to
the evil she's committing
she's so convinced of her destiny to
destroy tyranny that she's become
a tyrant daenerys tells jon to join her
fulfill his destiny and rule the galaxy
together
as nephew and aunt and jon makes his
choice
they embrace one last time and jon stabs
his lover in the heart
it's like the legend of azor ahai a hero
who sacrificed his lover to save the
world
there are lots of hints in the series
that jon is this prophesied hero
and it seemed as though that meant that
he would stop the white walkers
but in the end jon's destiny is to save
the world from
the woman he loves dany dies in his arms
like ygritte
jon chose duty over love the dragon
drogon sees daenerys dead
she was his mother she hatched him from
his egg
and for a moment it looks like he'll
kill jon but instead
drogon burns the iron throne cause in a
way
it was the throne that killed daenerys
the throne
represents power and all the ways that
power corrupts people
we saw cersei and joffrey and robert and
stannis all destroyed by power in
different ways
wars for the throne tore westeros apart
so the throne is the real enemy just as
much as the night king was
by destroying the throne drogon finally
breaks the wheel that daenerys talked
about
it ends the cycle of conflict in
westeros
symbolically at least and the throne is
destroyed in dragon fire just as it was
originally forged in dragon fire
it's like the one ring in lord of the
rings it also
symbolizes power and drives people mad
to possess it and is also destroyed in
the fires that forged it
drogon takes danny's body and flies east
dany thought that westeros would be her
home but it never felt like home
the east is where daenerys found love
and success so that's where she returns
in death in her vision in season 2
daenerys leaves the throne then goes to
be with her dead lover drogo
so now daenerys returns to her love
weeks later a meeting is held with the
high lords of westeros there's sansa for
the north edmure for the riverlands
robin for the vale
gendry for the stormlands yara for the
iron islands
and the new prince of dawn greyworm has
tyrion and jon prisoner
tyrion for his treason and jon for
killing daenerys
sansa has brought down an army of
northmen to secure
jon davos says the unsullied should
start their own house in the reach
which is a weird suggestion the
unsullied are eunuchs so
how could they start a noble family grey
worm says that he just wants justice for
the murder of daenerys so
you'd think that grey worm would have
just executed jon by now
jon murdered greyworm's queen surely the
punishment should be
death why does greyworm wait around and
ask
john's family for their opinion tyrion
says that they need to choose a new king
and edmure says he'd like to be king
edmure is sansa's uncle the red wedding
was his wedding and then he was
imprisoned by the phrase for half the
series
edmure is kind of a doofus so sansa
makes him sit
then sam suggests democracy he says the
king of westeros should be chosen by
all the people some parts of westeros do
have elections the night's watchmen vote
to choose their leader
and the ironborn lords elect their king
but the lords laugh at the idea of
giving peasants a vote
it's a big step from feudalism to
democracy
tyrion says that stories unite people
and bran has a great story
as the magic three-eyed raven bran is
the world's memory
he remembers the past so he should lead
westeros into the future
and all the lords agree to make bran
their king
which is a really weird choice these
lords don't know bran
and they don't know what a three-eyed
raven is they have no connection to the
magic of the old gods of the north
even to his own family bran is confusing
and mysterious to these southern lords
he's just a creepy
foreign [ __ ] bran also has no claim
on the throne for the last 300 years the
throne of westeros passed down
a line of succession that's why daenerys
had a claim as the daughter of the mad
king
jon snow has a better claim as the son
of the mad king's firstborn
jon also has a pretty good story and
he's an actual political leader who
people know
and support jon's identity as the true
heir to the throne was a mystery built
up throughout the whole series but his
claim
is not even mentioned in this scene
tyrion says they should ignore the line
of succession because the sons of kings
are often terrible
like joffrey ending the line of
succession is breaking the wheel
it's stopping a bad system but this
could just lead to
more conflict tyrion says that each new
king will be chosen by the lords of
westeros
which means every time a king dies
there'll be new uncertainty
at least the old system had the
stability of a royal family
now anyone can be king so it could turn
into a free-for-all every time a king
dies
sansa says that the north will be
independent from this new realm
all the other kingdoms will be ruled by
bran stark but the north will be ruled
by
sansa stark this whole meeting is
basically a stark
coup their family takes over westeros
and for some reason all the other lords
agree
what happened to their ambitions in
season 6 yara made a deal with daenerys
that the iron islands would be
independent
but now she kind of forgets that and
agrees to be ruled by
bran and dawn has a long history of
proud independence
and they should be in a strong position
now since their armies were untouched in
the recent wars
but this unnamed prince hands his
kingdom to the starks
this whole story was about ambitious
noble families fighting and scheming for
power
but now in one scene all the great
houses agree to give up their power to a
weird psychic kid because he has a good
story maybe everyone's just too tired
and confused to argue right now but
sansa set a precedent for kingdoms to
secede so there could be rebellions in
the future
this brave new realm is very delicate
and uncertain
but there is hope king bran
represents a different kind of ruler
past kings have been bad because they've
been proud or cruel
or power hungry bran doesn't care about
power
he has no pride or cruelty he barely has
a personality so in theory he'll be fair
and unbiased he'll be a good ruler
because he's
inhuman which is a very depressing
message
game of thrones was always about the
struggle between human good
and human evil within each person bran
being king suggests that the solution to
human evil
isn't human good it's being not human
and with a failure of jaime and daenerys
this whole season feels deeply cynical
about the very possibility
of human good bran makes tyrion
hand of the king which is another weird
choice
tyrion totally failed at being daenerys
hand and he ended up
betraying her tyrion's also widely hated
as the imp
kinslayer kingslayer and betrayer
it's hard to believe that any of these
lords even listened to tyrion at this
meeting
but bran says that tyrion will be handed
as punishment for his crimes
he'll spend his life fixing his mistakes
the starks want jon freed but grey worm
wants justice for daenerys
so they make a compromise jon is sent to
rejoin the night's watch where he was
in season one the purpose of the watch
was to defend the realm from white
walkers and wildlings
now the walkers are gone and the
wildlings are friendly so tyrion says
the watch will just be like a penal
colony for bastards and broken men
jon feels guilty and conflicted for
killing dany
she was a threat to his family and the
world but daenerys trusted and loved jon
daenerys was jon's queen and she was his
aunt which makes jon
a kinslayer a terrible crime in westeros
this makes jon the last targaryen and as
amon once said a targaryen alone in the
world is a terrible thing
tyrion says he'll visit jon that he'll
come and piss off the edge of the world
like when he visited in season 1. we see
some dothraki
at the docks in episode 3 it seemed like
all the dothraki died but apparently
many survived to the end
these guys were fanatically loyal to
daenerys they saw her
rise from fire twice and they followed
her across the world to win her westeros
so how did they react to dany's death in
season 6
dany made all her dothraki her blood
writers her sworn protectors
the books say that if a carl is killed
his blood riders live to avenge him
so surely when jon killed dany her blood
riders would be honor bound to kill jon
but here the dothraki just walk past jon
they don't even react to the man who
killed their khaleesi
what are the dothraki doing now that
dany is dead
when drogo died in season 1 his khalasar
scattered into warring factions
the dothraki way of life is to raid and
pillage other people in season one
daenerys was conflicted because she knew
that invading westeros with dothraki
would have
serious long-term consequences but the
show
never explores how the dothraki and
westerosi get along
there's only one named dothraki in
season 8 who only gets one line
the dothraki were part of dany's story
all series but in the end they get
no closure greyworm and the unsullied
sailed enough
because naf is misandi's home they
dreamed of returning there together and
for the unsullied to protect the nathi
so greyworm is honoring his dead
girlfriend's memory
in the books naf has a disease carried
by butterflies that kills foreigners
so hopefully that's not a thing in the
show but now that the unsullied are gone
who's forcing jon to stay at the wall
you'd think that most people would be
glad that jon killed the tyrant who
burned king's landing
king robert pardoned jaime for killing
the mad king
why doesn't king bran pardon jon for
killing the mad queen
as the last targaryen some people are
going to want to make
jon their king staying at the night's
watch could be a way to stay
out of politics that's why aemon joined
the night's watch
years ago aemon was almost made king of
westeros but instead he chose to join
the watch and to give up his claim so
that his brother could be king
instead maybe jon is staying at the
watch so his brother bran can be king
john's making another sacrifice for the
good
of the realm jon farewells his family at
the docks like frodo
in lord of the rings and sansa
apologizes for having jon sent north
she should probably also apologize for
breaking her oath and revealing jon's
parentage to undermine daenerys
that contributed to the conflict that
drove dany mad and got jon exiled
removing jon as king in the north and
making sansa
queen last season arya accused sansa of
undermining jon so that she can rule the
north
and that's kind of what ends up
happening sansa uses information to
create chaos and climb to power which is
exactly the strategy used by her mentor
littlefinger in season one sansa was a
naive girl who dreamed of being a queen
but she learned that queens and princes
aren't as wonderful as she thought
to survive sansa learnt politics from
some of the worst people in westeros
like littlefinger and cersei and those
people made sansa
who she is now so it is a triumphant
moment that someone who was abused for
so long
finally gets power of her own and no
doubt sansa will be
a strong ruler in the north she won't
make the mistakes that ned and rob
and john made but there's something dark
in that sansa got here by
embracing the lessons of her abusers as
well as of the starks
arya says she's not coming home she's
sailing west to discover new lands
as she said she would in season six so
aya is rejecting her life as a noble
lady and rejecting the violence of being
an assassin
her story was always intertwined with
death but now
she's killed the night king she's
defeated death and she chooses a life
of adventure and freedom instead but
she's also abandoning her family
in season six she declared she was arya
stark and her home was winterfell
but in season seven when she tried to
reconnect she ended up almost
murdering her sister after everything
she's been through arya feels
unable to come home like frodo she's
damaged so she sails into the sunset sea
it's kind of a metaphor for death and
practically speaking
everyone else who's sailed west hasn't
returned like this is some
columbus magellan edge of the world type
[ __ ] and i
is not exactly an expert sailor so arya
is
letting go of her old lives but she
keeps needle a symbol of her home
and family bran makes a weird comment
that jon was exactly where he
was supposed to be at the council he
hinted that becoming king
was bran's destiny all along bran has
had visions of the future before
and it seems like bran guided recent
events he gave arya the dagger that she
used to kill the night king
and he told sam to tell jon about his
parentage
which divided jon from dany leading to
her death and his exile clearing the way
for bran
to become king like sansa bran spread
information
that created conflict that gave bran
power like
littlefinger does in season seven
littlefinger gave bran
arya's dagger and brown quoted
littlefinger's line that chaos is a
ladder
littlefinger once said that you should
see all possibilities in your mind all
the time which is kind of what bran does
as the magic three-eyed raven
so did bran manipulate everything to
become
king it would be pretty evil if bran
knew that king's landing would burn
but he made it happen anyway but that's
exactly the sort of machiavellian magic
[ __ ] that the three-eyed raven
does like the previous raven used magic
visions to lure a crippled boy to a cave
full of skulls and deleted his
personality to make him into an avatar
for the ancient hivemind of the old gods
in the books the raven is called
bloodraven and he has an even longer
history of doing terrible things for the
sake of some
vague prophetic greater good bran stark
as we knew him is dead bran said that
he's not bran
anymore that he's the three-eyed raven
now so given the raven's long history of
psychic [ __ ] it's very possible that
bran has manipulated everyone around him
to gain
power what we call bran might now really
be
a puppet a host for the ancient psychic
hive mind of the old gods
what if the raven never gives up power
the previous raven said he's been alive
for a thousand years
sustained by the weirwood roots maybe
bran will become
an immortal god emperor like in 40k or
june
author george martin's old sci-fi
stories are full of evil hive minds
doing crazy [ __ ] like this
the show mostly avoids the high magic
stuff though so bran
is left ambiguous what he is and what
kind of king he'll be
is open to brienne becomes commander of
the king's guard
the highest and most respected position
for a knight of westeros
and there's a new symbol on the king's
guard armor in targaryen times the armor
had a targaryen dragon
under robert it was a crown when tommen
joined the sparrows it was the faith
star and now it's a three-eyed raven to
represent
bran this highlights again how weird it
is to make bran king
because the raven is a mysterious
mystical figure of the children of the
forest and the old gods who are only
worshiped in the north
and the north isn't even a part of
bran's realm
this would be like if the usa used a
canadian maple leaf to represent their
presidency
culturally and politically it's just
jarring
but as commander of the kingsguard it's
brienne's job to update the white book
which records the accomplishments of
every kingsguard knight
jaime's page had no great achievements
so he hopes to get some good deeds in
there before he
died so now brienne fills in jaime's
page
he took riverrun peacefully he
outsmarted dany's war plans and he
helped the living save the world from
the dead
brienne writes that jaime rode south to
save king's landing from destruction
which is not really
true jaime said he went south to be with
cersei he said she's hateful and so am i
jaime died saying that he and cersei are
all that matter in the world he died
hateful and his redemption failed but
one of the great lines in the books is
that men's lives have meaning
not their deaths jaime's death was a
failure but he did great things in his
life
and maybe that's what matters in the end
this
room is where jaime gave brienne the
sword oathkeeper where he showed her the
trust and respect that she needed
so the legacy of jaime's good deeds
lives on
even if jaime failed in death also
apparently
podrick has become a kingsguard knight
and it's great that he's rewarded but
kingsguard knights swear vows of
chastity they're not allowed to have sex
which seems a terrible waste for pod the
rod
the small council is the government of
this brave new realm
tyrion is hand davos master of ships sam
is grand maester bronn master of coin
and brienne's there as commander of the
kingsguard it's surprising that sam is
grand maester cause becoming a maester
takes years of study
sam just scrubbed bedpans stole books
and ran so is he qualified to represent
the citadel
and maesters take vows of chastity
they're not meant to have children
and wildling girlfriends maybe the rules
have
changed but braun as master of coin is
even more questionable
what does he know about responsible
fiscal management
a few seasons ago he said himself that
he doesn't know how
loans work and that'll be a problem
because the throne owes money to
the iron bank cersei never paid back her
loan to buy the golden company
we've been warned all series that the
iron bank is ruthless
they might start a war if they don't get
their money after all these years of
expensive conflict westeros
could face financial crisis and it's up
to bronn to prevent this
bronn is also lord of highgarden and
lord of the reach
tyrion kept his ridiculous promise and
made bronn one of the most powerful
lords in westeros
even though bronn is a disloyal amoral
murderer who threatened to kill tyrion
just two episodes ago
there are many powerful houses in the
reach who've wanted highgarden for
centuries
they're not gonna easily accept brawn as
their overlord
tyrion always said that he pays his
debts and bron does deserve a reward for
eight seasons of service to the
lannisters
but giving bronn this much power is not
a recipe for peace
sam has a new history book about the
recent wars it's called a song of ice
and fire which is the title of the game
of thrones book series
it's like how there's a lord of the
rings book at the end of lord of the
rings
throne's author george martin has said
that sam is the character most like him
so it's appropriate that it's sam who
presents this book
tyrion is upset to learn that he's not
mentioned in the history book
realistically tyrion would have been
mentioned he was handed to a king and a
queen
he killed tywin and he supposedly killed
joffrey
but this is a reference to what varys
said in season two that tyrion will
never get recognition and the histories
won't mention him
because he's a dwarf and a misfit he'll
always be misunderstood and hated
but that only makes tyrion more heroic
for fighting to make the world better
anyway king bran arrives and says they
need a master of war
which is ominous the master of war
position was invented by cersei
you'd hope that this new regime would
want to emphasize peace
not continue cersei's legacy bran also
says they need a master of whisperers
which is a spymaster
like varys and you think that bran could
just do that himself
since he can spy with animals and has
visions and claims to see
everything in the books the previous
three-eyed raven was once the master of
whisperers himself
and used his magic and spying to
basically run the realm for decades
king bran really is a continuation of
bloodraven's legacy
sam says that drogon is flying towards
volantis
if he continues that way he'll reach
valyria the ruined empire of the
dragonlords
and the homeland of the targaryens we
saw drogon in valyria before
so maybe he and daenerys are going back
to their ancestral home
bran says he might find drogon with his
magic but he doesn't say
why does he want to make sure that
drogon's safely
far away or does the three-eyed raven
have some sinister plan
bran lets the council do the ruling
while he goes and does
whatever the three-eyed raven does the
last line of dialogue in game of thrones
is tyrion telling his joke about the
honeycomb and the jackass
but once again we don't get to hear the
punchline
the scene pans out and we see the map of
westeros
it's cleared of rubble but there's still
a crack in the floor
because this new realm isn't perfect
there are problems and divisions and the
king is possibly an evil tree
but there are good people in government
and there's hope that the wounds
will heal the final scene in game of
thrones has jon and the wildlings riding
north
it seems like jon is escorting the
wildlings or maybe he's abandoning the
night's watch and joining the wildlings
he reunites with ghost and tormund maybe
he'll spend
his life with friends and have fun for
once instead of freezing his ass off on
the wall
the scene recreates shots from the first
scene in the series with
rangers riding north these rangers were
hunting
wildlings and got killed by white
walkers winter was rising against them
but now the watch is friendly with the
wildlings and the walkers are gone
and it seems like winter is ending the
first line in the game of thrones books
is we should start back but as jon and
the wildlings ride north
it feels like they're moving forwards
things aren't perfect but there's hope
it's a dream of spring author george
martin always said that the end of
thrones would be bittersweet
and it was sweet in the show to see
brienne knighted
sansa crowned theon redeemed we got
eight seasons of lannister drama
daenerys's conquests john and arya's
journeys
adapted from the books with exceptional
production
acting and music the tv show made some
nerdy fantasy books into the biggest
thing in pop culture with a global
community
of fans but it's bitter that the show
ended before the book series was
finished so for the last few seasons the
showrunners didn't have material to
adapt
they made up their own plots and tried
to connect them to the book ending that
the author told them
so sometimes there were dumb plotlines
like the white hunt
sometimes the dialogue was weak because
there was no book dialogue to use
characters like daenerys and jaime had
sudden twists in their stories which
felt rushed and undeveloped because they
were squeezed into shortened seasons
the politics lost the realism and sense
of consequences that defined the early
story
and the seasons of built up mystery and
magic with the white walkers kind of
went nowhere
complex characters like varys and
littlefinger and cersei became less
important while asshats like euron had
huge impacts on the plot without any
character depth to give that impact
meaning stuff happened not as a
consequence of character choices or
themes but simply to surprise the
audience
the main points of the ending on the
show are apparently partly the same as
what's planned for the books
but the show's ending doesn't have the
same depth and detail that gives the
books so much meaning
so it's bitter that we didn't get
daenerys's conflict with young griff
from the books
we didn't get the horror of book euron
and victarion
we didn't get the book dawn plot with
ariane and quentin
and alleras in old town or sansa with
harry in the vale and barristan in
meereen
and marwyn and macquaro varys and
illyrio's blackfyre conspiracy
and the northern conspiracy rickon on
skagos and stannis's battle of ice
lady stoneheart and patchface strong
belwas and
nimble dick crab we didn't get the full
prophecies of azor ahai
and the valonqar the mysteries of the
white walkers the night fort horn of
winter
ice spiders and a long long night and
everything else that'll happen in the
next two books martin recently hinted
that the next book will be out in a year
it'll be sweet to read his ending and
it's sweet that the tv show happened
but it's bitter that the show is not
what it could have been
alt shift x will make more videos on the
game of thrones books
we'll also make videos on other series
there are tv shows coming of watchmen
his dark materials lord of the rings
wheel of time
and movies of june there are also
netflix gems like dark
and maniac so these are the kinds of
series we'll make videos on
in future we'll hold votes and updates
at the old shift x patreon
there'll also be an alt shift podcast
about short stories
subscribe by the link below there's also
alt shift zed for readings of old books
ult swift x is some kind of parody
channel
and we don't endorse it but it also
exists
the game of thrones fan community has
been coming up with theories and
analysis since the 90s
places like westeros.org and the
subreddit the tumblers youtube channels
and podcasts
there are too many to name but you might
like to check out gliders
for some hard-hitting australian meme
core season 8 takedowns
thanks to the fan artists and the
caption translators and everyone who
sent nice messages to alt shift x
none of this would be possible without
you watching and supporting
so thank you thanks also to the random
article podcast for the spiritual
guidance without which this channel
would not exist old shift x is taking
some time off
there'll be no new videos for a while
latest updates are on patreon thanks to
patrons sam london of house wimbley
first of his name lord of union square
and protector of the realm
thanks to reverend zandrika cameron
weiss michael lapel jason rattray ryan
steele eric lewis dreyfus triangle wine
company harry neil choptika shane
veglier
jury bloody tyrant peter meehan stephen
placencia lve owen campbell kelly emily
mcnally nicos maria tarkis trace michael
ash josh fred petty chris coles and
bobby jose sayeth almazouri
zach gordon and disco dan cheers